viens ça c'est fait alors maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'il y avait d'autre
on va rester dans le sujet on va faire
une interview prise de tête
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien alors je vais répondre brièvement
sur des sujets graves c'est bien
Jean-Marie c'est bien
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles je
vous admire Jean-Marie c'est que vous ne
bougez pas pendant le jingle et vous
aussi d'ailleurs bien êtes-vous
favorable à la sexualité hors mariage
on est on est pas à l'abri et puis des
fois c'est bien de peut-être des fois de
toucher une autre peau une autre paire
de nichons un autre choupinette notre
odeur un truc comme ça donc vous êtes
vous êtes favorable à la sexualité hors
mariage
j'issais je suis un pauvre je suis un
pauvre je pense que faut pas engueuler
sans son mari que dans la veste tu
retrouves un préservatif je trouve ça
nul de faire une scène à son mari parce
que tromper sa femme avec un préservatif
c'est une petite bêtise trompée sa femme
sans préservatif c'est une grosse
connerie et donc je dis moi j'ai les
couilles en tout cas de dire ben moi que
je pars en tournée ma femme me prépare
ma valise mes chemises mes chaussettes
Mesli puis elle me met une petite boîte
de préservatif et pourtant je ne trompe
jamais ma femme mais c'est pour le cas
vous êtes favorable divorce
je sais que ça peut arriver et si jamais
c'est nécessaire bien sûr il faut il
faut le faire en ce qui me concerne moi
j'aime bien l'idée dans ma vie à moi de
mettre marié avec une femme et de ne
jamais la quitter jusqu'à la fin de mes
jours pour moi je trouve que c'est plus
samouraï quoi c'est plus bien est-ce que
vous êtes favorable à l'adoption
d'enfants par des couples homosexuels
voilà le lance pas la team a fait une
heure au téléphone non voilà non non
mais attends je peux développer un petit
peu parce que maintenant il y a un truc
qui est formidable avec le le pack si
jamais tu dis par exemple que tu es
contre le PACS tu passes pour un
homophobe tout le monde chie dans son
froc on veut pas être homophobe moi je
suis pas homophobe peut-être que
l'homosexualité était plus sexy du temps
où elle était sulfureuse c'était plus
sexy j'enchaîné que les petits couples
qui vont faire les courses ensemble chez
Auchan le matin non je dis simplement
que la République n'importe quel
gouvernement mais en tout cas la
République en général n'a pas à valider
ce n'est pas le travail de la République
de valider une tendance sexuelle ce
n'est pas un troisième sexe d'être
homosexuel ça concerne d'ailleurs à 80%
les hommes déjà faut le dire c'est pas
un truc qui concerne à la fois les
hommes et les femmes et simplement je
dis en déconnant à tous mes copains
homosexuels je leur dis le jour où on
endormira un enfant tu sais en lui
disant et le et le prince charmant
embrassa le prince charmant et il ne se
mariera pas il nure pas d'enfant
puisqu'il se bourraient le cul jusqu'à
la fin de leur jeu mais le véhicule sera
heureux mais ceci dit je n'ai rien je
n'ai rien du tout vraiment encore une
fois je le répète parce que c'est hyper
dangereux de parler de ça parce que
c'est la vieille crainte d'être de se
retrouver homophobe non le trou de balle
c'est une zone érogène formidable et
tout quand on passe un peu le doigt sur
le trou de balle c'est génial ça peut
même des fois de sauver d'une demi molle
je le donc moi je suis pas du tout
ennemi du dialogue au contraire
bien ça c'est fait alors maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'il y avait d'autre
la direction de Vidy par rapport à ce
que vous êtes pour l'adoption d'enfant
pour les couples homosexuels
a décidé de quoi que ce soit je veux
dire quand on parle d'amour quand on
parle d'enfant on en a rien à [ __ ] de
la République
elle a pas à défendre une tendance ou
instaurer une tendance je vais pas me
poser la question de est-ce que la
République est d'accord est-ce que le
bon Dieu est d'accord est-ce que est-ce
que machin est d'accord on s'en fout de
la République si on les enfants il doit
être élevé à mon avis il doit être élevé
entre un homme et une femme c'est quand
même mieux pour moi c'est la normalité
parce que je dis pas que d'être
homosexuel c'est anormal j'ai dit que
c'est une originalité d'accord un cas de
figure ça peut être mieux c'est que
c'est le gamin il est avec deux parents
con comme des valises et des mecs deux
autres fantastiques peut-être que là
dans ce cas précis ça peut être mieux
bien sûr mais je moi je parle pas là on
parle de théorie évidemment on est sur
le sur le papier sur le papier je dis
que l'épanouissement de d'un enfant
élevé par deux
d'homme je pense que c'est moins bien
que un homme et une femme j'ai le droit
de penser ça quand même bien sûr bien
alors Jean-Marie on continue l'interview
prise
l'avortement pour moi l'âme n'est pas
arrivé dans dans le foetus avant au
moins 6 mois et il y a pas une
destruction d'une personne c'est c'est
un embryon pour ceux qui pensent qu'ils
ont détruit une personne je pense pas
que ce soit le le cas ça n'est pas
suffisamment formé d'ailleurs c'est pour
ça qu'on peut pas sortir un bébé du
ventre de sa mère de moi et le faire
vivre parce que il n'a pas d'existence
encore le tanasie le tianazi je suis
contre parce que je pense que il faut
même si les souffrances sont terribles
je pense qu'il faut les vivre jusqu'au
bout et que comme je crois pas au hasard
encore une fois je pense que que il y a
différents cas de figure il y a des gens
par exemple la technique peut permettre
de rester de laisser brancher quelqu'un
et de le faire vivre même contre ça veut
dire que naturellement il n'aurait pas
vécu et il serait mort donc après le
fait de débrancher quelqu'un qui a le
cerveau tellement mort c'est très c'est
différent mais je parle l'euthanasiste
et dire donner la mort c'est pas retirer
un médicament c'est différent retirer un
truc qui fait vivre ces différents de
donner la mort mais donner la mort non
la peine de mort pour les assassins dès
qu'on dit le mot enfant tout le monde a
envie de tuer tout le monde si on tue
ton enfant sous tes yeux la peine de
mort tu vas pas attendre que les jurés
délibert tu vas mettre si tu as un
pistolet dans la main tu vas tu risques
de la donner la mort effectivement dans
tous les cas de figure je peux je
pourrais jamais dire que je cautionne la
mort et encore une fois comme le PACS
quand c'est la loi qui décide de dire
voilà on va prendre tel individu et on
va le tuer c'est c'est injouable
personne ne peut voter une loi comme ça
en revanche ce qu'il faut dire c'est que
tout le monde et à peu près d'accord
tout le monde une grosse majorité de
gens sont d'accord que quand il y a des
attaches pris dans un avion tu as des
mecs du GIGN ils se font avec une paire
de couilles énorme comme ça et qui
auront hommage d'ailleurs il rentre il
canardent et il tue les mecs et tout le
monde dit bravo et là il y a pas de
tribunaux il y a rien du tout on décide
de la peine de mort un mec rentre dans
une école bardée dynamique comme un
Neuilly rentre on lui met une balle en
citron et moi j'applaudis on a voté la
peine de mort là on est tous d'accord à
part quelques trous du cul qui dit on
aurait peut-être pu le garder en vie
mais moi mais moi moi je dis non parce
que moi je dis que si un mec rentre dans
une maternelle avec un paquet dynamique
sur lui si ce mec risque la vie de 30
enfants qui risquent au moins sa vie et
personne ne me contredira en disant que
depuis l'attaque qui a été faite sur
l'avion il y a plus jamais eu de
détournement il y en avait il y en avait
un tous les tous les six mois il y en a
pu parce que on se dit merde si je fais
ça c'est la mort sûr et certaine donc je
suis partagé entre les deux je ne la
cautionnerai pas je ne dirai pas qu'il
faut aller la donner mais en revanche la
loi c'est très très dur parce que ce qui
est écrit encore une fois c'est
exactement le thème de ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure ce qui est écrit n'est
pas valable il y a une loi pour chaque
situation
un mec il pique trois pizzas tu as
entendu ça il pique tu fais trois délits
dans certains dans dans certains états
des États-Unis trois fois le même délit
perpétuité c'était c'est un sketch si je
me mets avec le lot on fait un sketch là
dessus le mec il pique 3 pizzas il prend
perpétuité il y a un juge avec des mecs
qui sont là le juge il rentre chez lui
il dit à sa femme chérie j'ai fait mon
travail aujourd'hui il y a un mec il
avait piqué trois pizzas j'ai mis
perpète et tout le monde regarde dans le
plus grand pays du monde c'est-à-dire
que il est con le mec ben c'est s'il
prend une quiche
par exemple il échappe il échappe à
perpète il peut
nommer en plus si jamais si jamais ils
veulent les trois pizzas d'un coup il en
congèle deux pour lui ça il sera pareil
le préjudice et le même pour le mec il
va pas en prison comment est-ce qu'on
peut cautionner les lois comme ça c'est
la loi du cœur qui fonctionne et c'est
comme ça que j'essaye de répondre à tes
[ __ ]
la légalisation des drogues 12 je vous
demande pas si vous êtes d'accord la
légalisation des drogues 12 Ah oui non
oui oui bien sûr allons-y et la
libération de Maurice Papon
alors là la libération de Maurice Papon
c'est à mourir de rire moi j'aimais bien
Badinter je l'aime plus maintenant
il est vieux et tout c'est pas utile de
laisser en prison attends il est crime
contre l'humanité ce mec contre
l'humanité il y a crime il y a aussi
l'humanité oui d'accord mais seulement
ce mec on aurait préféré l'enfermer
quand il était jeune on aurait été
préféré mais on l'a eu que vieux
on la ferme vieux et malade et en plus
on l'enferme on le laisse enfermer et en
plus je trouve que c'est vachement sympa
d'être en prison vieux et malade ce qui
était un infirmier tu gâches pas tes
belles années c'est mieux mais ça veut
dire quoi de libérer un mec ça veut dire
que bon bah c'est fini non non non c'est
pas facile garder en prison ah moi je
pense qu'on le garde en prison il a
failli les juger il prend des années de
prison mec c'est quoi l'histoire quand
un gars s'ils veulent un scooter on le
colle on le colle en prison que d'un mec
il a tué une autre personne et tout ben
on le met en prison aussi et puis si
c'est un homme d'affaires des trucs et
ben aussi et le fils Mitterrand comme
Madame Mitterrand elle dit j'ai payé la
rançon là rançon moi j'aurais demandé 15
millions moi
la pas de rançon le mec on lui reproche
pas l'autre je vois j'entends le vice
mitterrandir il me regarde avec de la
haine dans les yeux il te regarde comme
il veut qu'est-ce que tu en as branler
si t'as rien à te reproché il peut te
regarder comme il veut
donc
bien sûr donc si tu es un
et donc ce juge moi je le trouve je le
trouve génial je
le trouve génial parce que même Pierre
Botton j'ai vu une interview et lui
aussi je l'ai trouvé formidable parce
que il dit bah comment il vous a enfermé
vous êtes tout pris et tout et il dit
ouais mais au bout du compte je pense
qu'il m'a remis sur les sur les rails et
on n'a jamais attaqué pour quelque chose
que je n'ai pas fait et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de Inna larditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu